[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en
france 24 hoy hablaremos sobre la
crítica situación que vive el líbano la
nación se encuentra sumida en una
profunda crisis económica social y
también política desde hace varios años
a la que se sumó la pandemia de kobe 19
y también la explosión ocurrida en el
puerto de beirut la situación ha llevado
a la ciudadanía a protestas recurrentes
y masivas luego de que la moneda
nacional perdiera casi la totalidad de
su valor además después de nueve meses
sin que los grupos políticos se pusieran
de acuerdo para formar gobierno el
primer ministro interino saad hariri
renunció a su puesto por diferencias con
el presidente de michel aun una decisión
que profundizó la incertidumbre en el
país y para analizar esta situación
saludamos a saiz ya el ex director del
núcleo de estudios de medio oriente de
la universidad austral de argentina sea
dicha ya muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
en primer lugar preguntarle en qué
situación queda el líbano no tras la
renuncia del primer ministro saad hariri
porque sigue siendo prácticamente
quiere formar un gobierno en el país
bueno parece que hemos vuelto a posarse
a la situación que teníamos el 5 de
agosto el día posterior a la explosión
y estamos no está atravesando como
alguna manera nuestra película el día de
la promo está en el regreso
a este día a este día trágico y entonces
nos ha podido como el gobierno sobre lo
que hay hay tres cuestiones de fondo
primer lugar una cuestión constitucional
es decir lo hemos la negativa del
presidente de dar el ok a la formación
el gobierno del primer ministro no está
es es una prerrogativa que tiene el
presidente es decir siglas como el
presidente esto no es posible que se
lleve a cabo en segundo lugar
hay una cuestión política envolvemos la
incapacidad de generar acuerdos en la
condición presidencial
representada por de una manera de los
dos socios principales que son hezbollah
y el movimiento patriótico libre desde
7.000 la oms contra el movimiento del
futuro de saab family y finalmente está
esta cuestión técnica
escucha no probablemente para que no nos
ponemos de acuerdo que las papas mini
proponen un había propuesto un gobierno
de corte este o reducido con unos 16
ministros el presidente había solicitado
un gobierno político no estuviéramos
salvados con diferentes facciones y más
amplios gobiernos 222 minutos ahora
leemos de la comunidad internacional no
que reclama que el líbano no sólo forme
el gobierno sino que también implemente
reformas estructurales de fondo para
combatir una corrupción que ya es
endémica no qué posibilidades reales hay
de dichos cambios se necesita mayor
presión por parte de la comunidad
internacional
con respecto al tema de la corrupción me
parece muy importante notar una cuestión
la semana pasada estuvo debatiendo
algunos avances no en relación al juicio
100 sé cuál fue la actitud del
parlamento negarse a votar la
posibilidad de juzgar el parlamento y el
ministerio del interior que impidió no
el cuestionamiento de los miembros de
las formas de seguridad
esto es esto es eso de una mengua genera
en el alma bronca en la población viaje
es todo lo que la capacidad de presión
de la comunidad internacional o el color
de paul baja hoy podría muy baja en el
sentido de que hemos visto todas las
gestiones que lleva adelante el
presidente macrón el año pasado sin
desgaste mayor entre agosto y septiembre
debemos que han caído en saco roto ahora
va a tratar de convocar entiendo a una
nueva conferencia internacional en
agosto esta conferencia cuenta con un
respaldo muy importante que es el de los
obispos de los economistas
del líbano con iniciativa también el
papá francisco que ha apoyado esta idea
pero hasta que no se resuelva la
cuestión acá no se olvida resolver la
cuestión entre realidades audita e irak
no aparece en esa puesta de laudar
estando no va a ser posible formar
gobierno en el corto plazo creo que el
mediano plazo puede ser que finalmente
tengamos un gobierno más cerca de fin de
año y que esté el gobierno cuyo cumple
de organizar las elecciones es peleón de
que es peronista si en abril de 2002
6 chayanne muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en este espacio de france 24
en esta audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informando hace en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]